it takes your 53 year old Scandal plague
son to work day Hunter bite and joining
Dad on his big trip to Ireland that's
definitely not a family vacation
masquerading as a taxpayer-funded state
visit like all good kids on a family
trip Hunters on his best behavior and
protecting pop from embarrassing
situations
[Music]
I'm here with my sister Valerie my
younger son Hunter Biden Stand Up Guys
I'm proud of you
that was painful while the bidens learn
more about their Irish Roots we are
learning more about hunter's cash
Pursuits the first Sons top staffers and
business associates made 80 visits to
the Obama White House which makes it
harder for the big guy to continue to
play dumb when asked about it
I've never spoken to my son about his
overseas business I have never discussed
with my son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss any
of your son's overseas businesses yes I
stand by that statement all right and we
just found out that Hunters now defunct
firm sought Irish government Investments
while his dad was VP in 2011 Dana that
rope line was
well it was it was a struggle to watch
it was
um
and also if your instinct is at the step
to covet or the steps to success is to
make sure we all don't have covid not
sure if that's a great grand strategy
for a second term if you're running for
re-election I do think that the media
coverage of this trip has been
absolutely appalling what is the
compelling National interest for America
for the president of the United States
to be in Belfast and and Dublin for five
days yeah I understand going to Mark the
The Good Friday agreement 25 years
America played a role great and then you
could move on but for five days
um he's going on a home visit it's
basically like a taxpayer-funded junket
yeah away and I do find it a little bit
strange that they will say that you know
scrutiny of Hunter is out of bounds but
then he goes on this taxpayer-funded
trip with his dad and he's standing
there helping his dad deal with a very
simple question from a child might have
been hard to hear it might have been
hard to understand with the with the
accent but it's just I think it's a
little bit bizarre and you know the
president of the United States
he issues a call to well a demand that
the American Auto industry be completely
transformed
something that affects every single
American and he goes to Belfast and
Dublin and won't take any media
questions yeah it's amazing he he can't
understand the child but he could tell
him exactly what shampoo he was using
which is amazing you know Jesse I bet in
that mysterious brain of yours you can
explain why Joe is why Joe went why is
Joe there what is going on
when you're Irish and you're president
you have to go to Ireland just like JFK
went to Ireland you have to make the
pilgrimage Obama went darling
is he Black Irish I don't think so
nicely done right so well he also went
to his homeland did where is he
from again America I'm just kidding the
tiny island nation of Hawaii
so all right you're right about the five
days though he doesn't have to go for
five days but listen this this might be
uh his his last term this might be his
last chance to go see the Home Country
this could be the swan song who knows we
had a guy last night who was the White
House stenographer under Obama Biden and
he was on the trip on Air Force two when
Joe first went to you we have tape of
that which you look like I'll play it
you can comment on it just like a real
show
[Laughter]
Joe Biden is lying Joe Biden is a
criminal that's the bottom line but he
signed up to be on barisma on April 18
2014. well on April 16 2014 what I've
seen in the laptop was Hunter put a
schedule uh something on his daily
schedule I'm meeting Devin and Lucas
Lucas Devin Archer's son Devin Archer is
a fellow barisma board member at the wh
this was a planning meeting for them to
start their uh Kickback scheme with
barisma I think that's called a rabbit
hole
well it's my lucky day because I went
down it and here's the answer Greg yes
we had a coup in Ukraine that we
encouraged and then all of a sudden he's
appointed the son to the barisma board
and then he shows up at the White House
with the other board member Devin and
then all of a sudden Joe flies over
there he's running point he requested
the Run point for Obama he Obama didn't
assign it he put his stand up and he
goes over there and one of the guys
briefs the plane in the back and says
we're going over there for energy and
natural gas oh that's suspicious I
thought you were going over there for
other things so then they get there and
then they throw a bunch of money at
Ukraine for energy who benefits barisma
and then he fires the prosecutor looking
into barisma I mean just follow that
timeline and that's pretty it's a
kickback scheme laid out for you is
pretty easy to understand
do you think Katie that Joe isn't aware
that like we get the news from Ireland
here like he thinks that like uh like
they can't it's like he's in Vegas
but he doesn't know where he is possibly
Hunter's trying to make him look better
by correcting him but he's actually
embarrassing him further by getting
involved and just remember the White
House is always saying we can't comment
on Hunter Biden because he doesn't work
for the White House we have nothing to
do with him we talk to his lawyers and
yet here he is correcting his statements
uh to these folks and this is an example
of why they're not doing a press
conference for reporters who have
repeatedly asked for one they're walking
around like they know nothing's going to
happen to Hunter Biden despite the fact
that he's under federal investigation
um clearly Joe Biden knows that the
Press isn't going to you know ask him
questions about their partnership that
they had when they were doing all these
business dealings so they're happy to
have a family trip just like the one
when Hunter Biden flew on Air Force two
with Joe Biden to Beijing and came back
with a bunch of deals so that's where
they are they don't think nothing's
going to happen so they just shamelessly
walk around on their vacation in The
Green Room Jessica you said you'd never
were more ashamed of being a Democrat
than today
it's weird I don't recall it going that
way but
um I can I can play with that
um
so they're obviously sending a very
clear signal that Hunter Biden is here
to stay and they're not backing off of
this at all he has other kids he could
have taken them
he chose to do this what he has other
grandkids too yeah the stripper baby one
what she doesn't talk about you should
have taken the stripper baby that
stripper baby is never going to go to
Ireland
she may go to Ireland well she's gonna
have to say stripper money
baby's not a stripper it's my mom well
you know the odds are it could end up
being a stripper that's not true
anyway
so apologize to the baby sorry baby
members on these trips his sister was
also with him the White House released a
statement saying that they're paying for
their expenses
but the real thing is it to your point
Katie where they say they know nothing
is going to happen to them
Congressman James Comer was on Fox and
Friends yesterday just being had a very
nice interview and then at the end Steve
Ducey said hey you got anything you've
been doing this for a while now we've
been talking about what's going to
happen Hunter Biden and his dad the most
corrupt twosome you know in American
history and comer
waffled around for a while he said a lot
of IFS
this if that if we can show this net
result they don't have anything yet and
I have a million dollars going into the
Biden family bank accounts from China
why isn't the big guy and Hunter Biden
in The Slammer because
you don't care and cover it I don't care
I have to talk about it every day I care
media people you disgusting people they
don't have anything he was a republican
he'd already be in The Slammer you know
it and I know it we gotta go we gotta go
I'd like to apologize to all stripper
babies out there
it's not your fault that baby deserves a
lot better don't
bother exactly pretending
that's where we ended up so the child
doesn't exist you are a mother and you
should be defending this stripper baby
we're going to do the rest of this hour
on the stripper baby
we're gonna blow the brakes
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now